it's great to be joined today by dr.
Alok Kanodia who's a psychiatrist
practicing in Boston Massachusetts he's
on the faculty at Harvard Medical School
and he's been using meditation along
with the latest advances in neuroscience
and psychotherapy to help gamers who may
be experiencing a video game addiction
get control of their lives thanks so
much for talking to us about this IV
first thing is there something unique
about video game addiction that is
different than other addictions
absolutely David thanks for having me on
the show by the way um so I think the
first thing to understand is that our
model of addiction is based on
biological addictions so things like
alcoholism for example is one of the
most common addiction and right now
there's like an opiate crisis across the
United States and so those substances
those are what we call substance use
disorders and so those are chemicals
that have a direct effect on a
particular part of your brain and so our
treatment of addictions tends to be
based on things like alcoholism but a
video game doesn't affect people in the
same way is like a molecule of alcohol
or a molecule of like heroin or cocaine
Gaming is much more complex and affects
people in a whole slew of neurological
psychological and even kind of social
ways can you talk a little bit about I
mean if we imagine two people someone
who may be playing video games 10 hours
a day and someone who may be watching
reality television 10 hours a day the
amount of time that goes into it is the
same the amount of time sitting in front
of a television is effectively the same
but these are two different behaviors
right absolutely can you talk about how
or why so if we think about someone who
watches reality television first of all
I I don't know I've never met someone
who watches 10 hours of reality TV for
like years and years and years whereas
I've met a ton of gamers who will be in
their mid-twenties and have really done
nothing except for play video games for
like six to ten hours a day for the last
decade
so I think just in terms of the
commonality of video game addiction is
way higher than let's say reality TV but
fundamentally if you think about the
person who's watching reality TV that's
entirely a passive consumption of
something
whereas video gaming is way more active
if you look at gamers part of the reason
that they stay so engaged with games is
because there are social aspects to it
for example like people will have you
know online friends on their Steam
friends list that give them a sense of
community that they actually get to know
very well over time I mean myself
included so I for example started
playing Starcraft with a guy I when I
was 15 years old had never met the dude
and then 12 years later I've been
playing with the guy like you know on a
weekly basis for the last decade I
invited him to my wedding and so I think
aiming has a very powerful community
aspect in which people form authentic
relations which keeps people kind of
plugged into the computer because as
human beings we want to connect with
other people and gaming actually allows
you to do that another big aspect that
separates gaming from kind of passive
consumption is that a lot of gamers
derive identity from the game so they
think of themselves as oh I'm a
competitive player in this game or
they'll create a character in a
massively multiplayer online RPG like
World of Warcraft or FF 14 or Elder
Scrolls online and they sort of identify
with with this person that they are in
the virtual world and they derive a
sense of kind of pride in their identity
I know a lot of gamers for example who
take a lot of pride in accomplishing
things within games and if you think
about someone who's watching reality TV
there's no sense of accomplishment there
ever and I think that's why video games
are such a big problem because they do
actually hijack parts of our brain that
involve reward circuitry that and will
involve overcoming challenges that
involve achieving things and so I think
the two are actually very different does
that make sense
it does yeah is it is there a way to
objectively say that video game
addiction or
equivalent addictions are quote less
serious or quote less damaging than
addictions to some of the substances you
mentioned or is it not so clear that we
can say that I think less damaging so I
think they're more damaging in some ways
and less damaging than other ways and
and you can sort of say that
scientifically for example there are
cases of people who died from video game
addiction but those tend to be very few
and far between so I can think of like
two or three case reports over the last
three or four years people who have died
a video game addiction whereas we know
that for example alcohol heroin cocaine
those will kill you like people died
from liver disease they die from
overdosing on alcohol they die from
overdosing on opiates and that's a very
common situation I think that so in that
way you can say that biological
addictions are more dangerous if we're
defining danger as you know risk of
mortality on the other hand I think
actually gaming addiction can be more
dangerous in a lot of ways because of
the way that it's insidious and sort of
takes control of someone's life there
are a lot of gamers who actually kind of
are very happy and and sort of fine with
playing games for like six to ten hours
a day and in that sense I mean there are
some alcoholics who don't think that
they have a problem as well but I think
because gaming is just so much fun and
because it engages people on so many
different levels like for example
earlier I was talking about how you can
form authentic relationships I think in
a sense it can be even more dangerous
because it's giving you something that
the real world gives you and therefore
sort of takes away the need for you to
engage in the real world and when I
think about how that shapes someone's
life I think it's very very dangerous
because you're sort of you enter this
virtual world and then before you
realize it you're not really able to
move in the real world and you kind of
don't know how you ended up there are
men versus women more or less likely to
be
addicted and I know that we need to
account for the fact that there are
gender differences in terms of who plays
video games right like there are way
more male gamers than female gamers to
begin with and there's also probably
different social stigma around mental
games versus women but what do we know
about whether men versus women are more
likely to become addicted so that's a
great question and and the answer is
unfortunately it depends so for example
one study out of South Korea that looked
at adolescents demonstrated that if you
for the people who were addicted there
was a four to one ratio of male men to
women in terms of who qualifies as a
video game addict but then there are
other studies that look at sort of that
aren't quite so specific and are a
little bit broad that suggests that the
kinds of video game addiction that each
gender has seems to be different so for
example women will are much more likely
to spend more time playing mobile games
or like iPad games or things like that
and you know men are much more likely to
play things like overwatch and so there
does seem to be a gender difference in
terms of how they engage but it's a
little bit unclear whether and there is
some data to suggest that video game
addiction is more of a problem in men
but then there are other pieces of data
that are less how can I say this that
are less high-quality which suggests
that the amounts of addiction may be
comparable if you look at it in the
right way
and one example of that for example if
you lump in Internet addictions into
social media addiction and gaming
addiction women are much more likely to
be addicted to social media and men are
much more likely to be addicted to video
games and so some people hypothesize
that that that's actually a common
disorder and it's kind of like an
Internet addiction in which case it's
kind of the same is that too complicated
of an answer no not for me and we have
an extraordinarily smart audience so I
can't imagine it would be to too much
for them either let me ask you this when
it comes to treatment of video game
addiction is it mostly psychotherapy
of behavioral therapy or I guess let me
ask it in a different way some
conditions like OCD or others that you
know we have different degrees of
understandings for we found that there
is some success in treating them with
different types of medication right
pharmacological treatment is there
anything like that for video game
addiction or is it mostly in the realm
of psychotherapy so that's a fantastic
question and the short answer is video
game addiction is so new that we
actually don't have a good treatment for
it
it hasn't been well studied in terms of
randomized control trials but once again
the most high quality research on video
game addiction comes out of South Korea
and there are some studies that show
that for example there's a specific
medication called wellbutrin or B
proprio n-- which has been shown to help
people treat it so it's a medication for
depression ADHD and can even help people
with nicotine addiction so smoking
cessation and that seems to be the the
medication that works the best or
helping people who have a video game
addiction problem at the same time there
are multiple studies that suggest that
cognitive behavioral therapy is
effective tends to be equally effective
to other kinds of therapy excuse me and
then there are some studies that suggest
that combining the two which tends to
usually be the case is superior to doing
either one in my personal experience I
think that video game addiction is is
kind of a complicated entity I don't
think it is a disease the same way that
let's say cancer is a disease and so
when I work with people with video game
addiction I try to understand what is it
that keeps them sitting in front of the
computer screen is it some form of
social anxiety is it because they're
afraid to take chances in the real world
is it because they just find the game to
be more engaging than the rest of life
which is frequently the case and I think
that ultimately the most effective a
treatment for an addiction is to really
target individuals and try to figure out
is this like a social thing is it an
identity thing is it like a dopamine
thing is it a way that you
hope with your problems and so you have
to kind of understand why the person is
addicted to the game and then you kind
of target that treatment what worked for
you I mean you people would have no
necessarily reason to know but you
almost failed out of college because of
excessive video gaming I don't know if
you'd call it a gaming addiction what
what ultimately worked for you I mean so
I found something else that really
interested me so I think the the big
problem with a lot of gamers and this is
going to be a little bit of a roundabout
answer but a while ago one of my
supervisors once explained to me that a
smart kid in school is actually like a
special-needs kid that if you have a kid
who's intelligent they actually require
a certain kind of stimulation and
challenge in order to keep them engaged
and successful at school and when I work
with a lot of video gamers there's a
very common pattern of these these guys
are smart they're actually smarter than
the average population and there's data
to support that and so early on what
happens with these kids is they go to
school and then they get bored because
you know you learn arithmetic on Monday
and then for the next two weeks all
you're doing is arithmetic because
school moves at the pace of the slowest
person in the class and then you give a
bright kid something like a video game
where the second you beat level one a
more challenging level is waiting for
you and that's incredibly addictive just
the intellectual engagement that moves
at your own pace is incredibly addictive
to someone who's smart and so what
happened for me is I found something
else that I found so engaging in that I
could kind of grow and move at my own
pace and learning and that happened to
be like meditation in Eastern medicine
and I basically decided that I wanted to
become a monk and found that just to be
really engrossing so when I work with
gamers now one of the the key principles
for treating an addiction and how to
overcome your addiction is to find
something that you care about just as
much to find a competing interest
absolutely yeah absolutely fascinating
and I'm sure I thought when you said
meditation I thought you were gonna say
downhill ski jumping you found which you
just loved so much more but
meditation makes more sense I think for
sure we've been speaking with dr. Alok
Kanodia who's a psychiatrist here in
Boston Massachusetts thanks so much for
talking to us about this thanks a lot
David